[موسيقى]
قالت المعارضه السوريه ان حي جوبر في دمشق
سجل اول استخدام من جانب النظام السوري
للطائرات الحربيه للاغ على اهداف في
العاصمه بعد ان كان يكتفي بالمروحيات
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
فقط
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر نناقشه في عنوانين
رئيسيين اي جديد طرا على الساحه العسكريه
في البلاد دفع النظام السوري لاستخدام
المقاتلات ضد العاصمه وهل يمكن الحديث عن
سيطره للنظام في دمشق على الارض وهو
يقصفها بالطيران الحربي من
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الجو ليس امرا جديدا ايق صف الاسد عاصمته
من الجو فعلها من قبل باستخدام المروحيات
لكن الجديد ان يستخدم طائرات الميج
المقاتله لقصف حي من احياء العاصمه اي
دلالات يمكن قراءتها من اقدام حاكم على
قصف حاضره بلاده بالطيران البعض يرى انه
سعي من النظام لحسم سريع في العاصمه
واخرون يرون انه دليل افلاس يثبت عدم
القدره على السيطره الميدانيه على
الارض الله اكبر قنابل فراغيه واخرى
عنقوديه وبراميل متفجره يسع القاموس
السوري كل مفردات الموت الممكنه فالنظام
هناك ماض في تنفيذ هجماته الحاصله ارواح
المدنيين من الارض والجو غاره الجويه
اضافت الى اهدافها الان دمشق العاصمه فطير
الاسد الحربي قصف عاصمته لاول مره نزلت
القنابل على حي جوبر عند طرف دمشق الشرقي
غير بعيد عن بلده
التي يسيطر عليها الثوار كما تجدد القصف
الجوي عنيفا على احياء الريف
الدمشقي الغارات مدعاه لتساؤل مزدوج لماذا
دمشق ولماذا الطائرات المقاتله الحقيقه
انه لم يسبق للنظام السوري ان استخدم
الطائرات ذات الاجنحه الثابته في قصف
اهداف في دمشق فكيف بطائرات الميج المقتصر
استخدامها عاده على الحروب
النظاميه كانت المروحيات تنفذ ضربات على
اهداف يقول الجيش النظامي السوري انها
مواقع للجيش الحر فهل لاستبعادها الان صله
باسقاط بعضها بدفاعات لم يعد سرا ان
الثوار
يملكونها ومع ان استخدام النظام السوري
للطيران الحربي ازداد في الايام الاخيره
فان دمشق تدخل على قائمه اهدافه لاول مره
يفسر بعض الخبراء العسكريين ذلك بمسعى
النظام الى حسم المعركه هناك لما تمثله
العاصمه من اهميه لكل نظام ويرى اصحاب هذا
الراي في انسداد افق الحل السياسي وغياب
رد فعل دولي حازم على مجازر يقترفها نظام
الاسد بحق المدنيين عوامل تشجعه على المضي
فيما يسميه خيار الاجتثاث في المقابل ثمه
من يفسر القصف الاعمى لعاصمه البلاد بحاله
من الضعف تنتاب القوات
النظاميه فهي لا تقتحم حيا الا بعد ايام
من الق
فاذا دخلته بعد تدميره فانها سرعان ما
تجبر على الانسحاب انها براي ناشطين غير
قادره على المواجهه المباشره على الارض مع
الجيش الحر الاقل تسليحا لكن الامهر في
تطوير اساليب قتاله فثو وهم الطرف الاضعف
المفترض نجحوا في تحويل المعركه من الدفاع
الى الاستنزاف لقد انتقلوا من قتال
الاحياء والمدن الى استهداف حواجز الخصم
بل اثروا قائمه انتصاراتهم في الايام
الاخيره على اكثر من
جبهه للمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا في
الاستديو العميد صفوه الزيات الخبير في
الشؤون العسكريه والاستراتيجيه ومن
اسطنبول المعارض والناشط السياسي السوري
وليد البني ومن لندن هيثم سباهي عضو
النادي الاجتماعي السوري ولعلي ابدا بضيفي
في لندن لمحاوله فهم هذا التطور استعمال
المقاتله ثابته الجناح طائرات الميج في
استهداف ليس فقط مناطق خارج العاصمه دمشق
ولكن استهداف احياء في العاصمه دمشق ما
تفسير ذلك
سيدي اولا مساء الخير لكم مشاهدك الكرام
مساء لضيفك في الاستديو يعني الوضع في
منطقه جوبر ومنطقه عربين وسب وحمريه هي
خاليه تماما او شبه خاليه من
المدنيين المسلحين عندما يدخلون بمجموعه
صغيره يعني تتراوح بين ال 50 او 75 او 100
يحتمون في في ابنيه او مناطق ضيقه
جدا تخرج الفتحات الصغيره وتصعد القناصه
على على هذه البيوت فمن الصعب
دخول جنود سوريين التكلفه ستكون عاليه هذا
انا انا لست عسكريا لكن هذا ما اعرفه من
من اصدقائنا ومن اهالينا في دمشق التكلفه
عاليه بين الجنود والدوله هناك لا تريد ان
تعرض هؤلاء الجنود للقتل او او الجروح
البليغه من قبل القناصين المتحصنين خلف ه
هذه ال الابنيه او داخلها يعني فيضطرون
القصف وتدمير المبنى مع القناص سويه ا
طبعا لنسال لنسال معنا هنا في الاستديو
الخبير العسكري اللواء صفوه الزيات عن هذا
التطور استعمال طائرات ثبته الجناح
وتحديدا في العاصمه دمشق وتحديدا في حي
جوبر هل من تفسير لذلك يعني اعتقد التفسير
الاهم انه لم يعد يتوفر لديه على الارض
قوه بريه قادره على الاقتحام سواء في شرق
او في جنوب غرب او جنوب شرق
العاصمه اصبح ايضا يعاني كثيرا الهليكوبتر
لديه ربما هناك تقارير ان اصبح لديه اقل
من 10 طائرات من طراز هند
25 الطائره الهليكوبتر المسلحه وايضا ربما
يستخدم طائرات ال المي 8 ومي 17 وهي
طائرات هليكوبتر للنقل ولكن يبدو ان
خسائرها بدات تكسر اذا هو لم يعد لديه
الان غير غير ربما استخدام هذه الطائرات
المقتله هو يستخدمها ومن المؤكد انه يعاني
كثيرا في هذا هو لا يريد ان يقدم نفسه
للعالم انه يخصف ح حاضرته والزميل في لندن
يتحدث انه الافضل عنده عنده ان يزيل مباني
بكاملها ان يلغي الحياه على الارض تماما
ان ينهي البيئه البشريه والبيئه الاساسيه
لا مانع عنده من اجل بضعه ربما افراد
تسللوا لكن المشكله الخطيره التي لديه انه
اصبح يعاني من عقده الحصار هو خسائره
الكبيره واستنزافه في حلب هذا التفوق
الكبير للثوار الذي تم في ادلب ربما ايضا
في درعه يبدو الامر ايضا هناك قتال على
مدار اليوم بدا يشعر انه ربما مصيره في في
النهايه سينتهي في دمشق اذا قرات خريطه
دمشق تجد ان حرستا ودوما والمناطق التي
يستخدم فيها بكثافه الطائرات الثابته
الجناح وايضا اذا حتى تكلمنا عن حي جوبر
دعني اقول لك حي جوبر لا يفصله عن الغوطه
الشرقيه الا الهاي واي او المتحلق الجنوبي
وبالتالي هي مناطق مترابطه مع بضه هو يعلم
تماما ان نافذه دمشق الى وسط سوريا والى
شمال سوريا والى شرق سوريا هي الغوطه
الشرقيه السؤال الان عن اذا خرج خرج
الدومه عن سيطرته فلك تتصور هناك ثلاث
قواعد على مسافه بسيطه
للغايه لنصف طائرات القتال التي لديه
وبعضها انواع لم لم يستخدمها بعد هو يشعر
ان الغوطه الشرقيه بالنسبه له هي مساله
حياه او موت بالدرجه الاولى طيب اتوجه الى
اسطنبول ومعنا من هناك ضيفنا النش السياسي
السوري وليد البن سيد وليد كيف تنظرون الى
ه التطور استعمال الطائرات بالقدره
التدميريه التي تملكها الطائرات في احياء
مقتضى بالسكان وان كان ضيفنا من لندن يقول
بان هذه احياء فارغه من السكان ولا يوجد
بها الا
المقاتلين عدد سكان دوما نصف مليون نسمه
عدد سكان عربين ما الف نسمه جوبر تبعد عن
ساحه العباسيين واح ك متر فقط فقط عندما
يضطر النظام ان يقصف هذه المناطق الكثيفه
السكان بالطيران هذا دليل انه لم يعد
يمتلك ما يكفي من الجنود حتى يسيطر حتى
على الضواحي القريبه من دمشق استراتيجيه
النظام هي القتل والقصف والتدمير هو يهدد
السوريين بانه سيدمر سوريا باكملها فوق
رؤوسهم اذا ما استمروا في رفضهم لاستمرار
حكمه المستبد منذ اكثر من 43 عاما لا ادري
من اين يعلم الاخ في لندن بان منطقه دوما
مثلا خاليه من السكان او منطقه جوبر انا
من تلك المناطق دوما وحدها 600000 نسمه
اين ذهب طيب التل تم تدميرها بالكامل
منطقه جديده عطوز قدسيه كل ريف دمشق يتم
تدميره بشكل كامل الدومه حرست كانت ملجا
يتم قصفه الانل لا ادري حقيقه كيف يستطيع
نظام ان يبرر ل طيب نحن فقط في هذه الحلقه
في هذه الحلقه سيد وليد ان كنت تسمعني
سنركز على العاصمه دمشق باعتبارها التطور
الابرز ان تقصف او يقصف حي داخل دمشق
بطائرات من نوع الميك وهنا اتوجه بسؤالي
لضيف في لندن السيد هيثم عندما يقصف حي في
دمشق ايا كانت المعطيات على الارض كما
ذكرتها قبل قليل هذا دليل قوه ام دليل
ضعف
لا د دليل حفاظ على قواته يعني نحن نعرف
بالضبط انا احترم السيد وليد
البني لكن كمان نحن لدينا عائلات في دمشق
ولدينا اصحاب هذه المناطق عندما يدخلها
المسلحون يهرب المدنيون لم يبقى احد
يستطيع ان فتح محله اذا دمرت المحلات
وسرقوا البضائع
يروعون الاهالي الاهالي ال لا يدين شيء
انا تكلمت مع دمشق ومعظم الناس في دمشق
تقول لقد سئمنا به الوضع هذه ليست بثورات
ولا ليست بحريات ولا ليس هذه اعمال
تخريبيه وان كان وان كان هذا سيد سيد هيث
وان كان هذا ليس موضوعنا عفوا ليس موضوعنا
في هذه الحلقه ولكن نتكلم على هذا التطور
وارتباطه بتطورات ميدانيه عندما يتعلق
الامر بالعاصمه دمشق واو ان كان له حسابات
سياسيه لدى هذا الطرف او ك بما فيها ال
النظام ايه العميد صفوت عندما يتعلق الامر
بهذا التطور بالعاصمه دمشق وهذا الحي حي
جوبر ما الذي يمكن ان يؤثره سلبا استعمال
طائرات في العاصمه دمشق على اهداف النظام
سواء كانت مقصوده من ورائها او كانت عن
اكراه باعتبار الوضع بهذه الطريقه يعني هو
اعتراف من النظام بلا شك انه نفذ هذا
الامر وهو مكره للغايه في قواعد دائما
حروب الثورات من مثل هذا النوع لدينا
دائما ثلاثه خطوات الخطوه الاولى كليل
كلير يعني عليك ان تطهر المنطقه ثم هولد
عليك ان تتمسك وتستعيد البنيه الاساسيه
فيها والامر الثالث ان تعيد تسليمها الى
السلطات المدنيه لاداره الحياه اليوميه
يبدو انه لا يستطيع حتى منذ بدء الثوره
ودعني اقول لك هو اول استخدام للمدفعيه
كان في يناير هذا العام الهليكوبتر بدينا
نشاهدها في سماوات سوريا في يونيو في
اغسطس الماضي فقط بدات القوه الجويه يعني
لدينا نوع من التسلسل في استخدام عنف اكبر
وهذا بيؤثر الى ان القوه البريه ليست بخير
ولكن لا ننسى ايضا عذره للمقاطعه لا ننسى
ايضا بان النظام كان قد هدد بانتهاء
الهدنه بانه سوف يضرب بقوه من اجل اجتثاث
من سماهم بالارهابيين وبالتالي مثلا يوم
البارحه في اكثر من نقطه تم استعمال
الطائرات طائرات الميج وقصفت وبالتالي ما
جرى في دمشق لا يمكن عزله عن ما جرى بقيه
المناطق يعني دعني اقول لك في في مثلا على
سيب المثال في حلب هو لم يضرب حي الشهباء
لم يضرب حي الفرقان يضرب الى حد ما الان
يرمون لانها بدات تخرج عن سيطرته فدعني
اقول لك في بعض المناطق هو لم يستخدم هذا
العنف الذي استخدمه ربما في العاصمه ولكن
الاخطر انت كيف تقاتل في حلب وكيف تقاتل
في معره النعمان وكيف تقاتل في ذرعه وكيف
تقاتل في مناطق اخرى وانت اساسا لا تستطيع
ان تخرج من العاصمه هو ما زال يح يحلم بم
ظر جروزني في اوائل 2000 عندما بوتين
حولها الى انقاض وسحب دخان نتيجه
لاستخدامه نفس انماط الذخائر التي
يستخدمها الان القنابل العنقوديه هي هي
القنابل الفراغيه هي هي التي استخدمها
بوتين ربما القنابل المضاده
للاليات المدرعه امور كثيره للغايه
استخدمت لم يعد امامه يبقى الا السلاح
الكيماوي في كل الا في كل الامور حتى
والزميل بيتحدث من من لندن وهو بلا شك
يدافع عن النظام لكن في نفس كلماته تتضمن
اعتراف بان الامر وصل الى مراكز القياده
السياسيه سطيه الص يجيب عادي عن هذه
النقطه ولكن اتحول ضيفي في اسطنبول السيد
وليد البني عن ما اهم المؤشرات عندما يقوم
النظام بفعل ما فعله في حي
جوبر في الحقيقه اهم ما يمكن استنتاجه بان
عدد المنشقين هو بازدياد
اشقائنا جميع السوريين يرفضون للذهاب
للخدمه في جيش النظام لان اي جندي يذهب
للخدمه في جيش هذا النظام هو سوف يقوم
بقصف اهله وذويه حتى في المناطق التي
طالما ادعى النظام انه يحميها او يحاول
زورا ان يقول انها تنتمي اليه الاخوه في
المناطق الساحليه بداوا يرفضون ارسال
ابنائهم لكي يقتلوا من اجل ان يبقى الاسد
حيا هذه هي الاسباب جعلت انه لم يعد يمتلك
قوه عسكريه كافيه قوه بشريه كافيه قادره
حتى على السيطره على جوبر الذي كما قلت
لكم يبعد عن مركز العاصمه عن المركز وهو
حي دمشقي اكثر من ثلاثه كيلومترات وعن
ساحه العباسيين مئات المترات هذا دليل بان
هذا النظام يتهاوى وهو يحاول ان يستخدم كل
ما يملك من بطش انا لا اعتقد ان هناك
عاقلا في الدنيا كان
طيب
دم في الجزء الثاني من هذه الحلقه سوف
نتناول هذا المعطى المعطى على الارض
والمعطى على الجو واستعمال هذه الطائرات
طائرات الميج فيما يتعلق بمدى القدره على
السيطره على الارض فيما يتعلق بالعاصمه
دمشق بعد
الفاصل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد الى هذه الحلقه والتي
نناقش فيها ما اعتبر تطورا نوعيا باستعمال
النظام في سور طائرات الميج في قصف حي في
داخل العاصمه دمشق واوجد تحيه بضيوفي هنا
في الاستوديو وكذلك في لندن وفي اسطنبول
واتوجه ضيفي في لندن السيد هيثم سباهي عضو
النادي الاجتماعي السوري الى اي مدى يسيطر
فعلا وبشكل كامل على العاصمه دمشق بريا من
قبل قوات النظام مدام انه يستعمل طائرات
من نوع ميك في حي لا يبعد الا مسافه ق
يعني قليله جدا على ساحه العباسيين في
دمشق لا الجميع في دمشق يعرف ان هناك
اختراقات لا تستطيع السيطره على مجموعات
صغيره من اربع او خمس اشخاص او ع اشخاص
ياتون ليجتمعوا في
مكان ويصبح العدد 20 او 30 في روعوا
الاهالي في المنطقه هناك مناطق يعني سوريا
ليست فقط جوبر وثقب وحمور وبعض المناطق في
حلب هناك مناطق كثيره في سوريا ولم نرى
هذه الطائرات ولم نرى الجيش السوري يقصف
ويضرب الجيش السوري والقوات الامنيه تعالج
كل حدث على حدا هناك دخول لمسلحين لبعض
المناط ناق على القوات السوريه ان تدرس
الوضع وتدرس عملياتها فاذا كان هناك اي
خطر على الجنود السوريين في مناطق ضيقه
جدا ومناطق يعني لا يستطيع العميد صفوت
يعرف هذا جيدا لا يستطيع الجيش ان يدخل
بدباباته او عليه اذا كان هناك اطلاق قناص
من قناص او اثنين في مبنى فليقصفوا يعني
الشعب في دمشق او في حلب او الشعب السوري
باجله لقد سئم من هذا الوضع وسئم من هذه
العمليات هذه عمليات تخريب وتدمير بايدي
خارجي السيد وليد البني لماذا هو في
الخارج عليه ان يرجع الى سوريا حسن عبد
العظيم وكلهم في دمشق ليتكلم على الطاوله
هو
سياسي ان تاخذ وقتك في المداخله ولكن فقط
رجاء ان نبقى في في حد
ذاته ال الموضوع هناك مناطق وهناك بؤر
توتر في دمشق وفي يعني مناطق في حمص وفي
ادلب وفي حلب هؤلاء يدخلون من الحدود
التركيه باعداد كبيره ومسلحين ويدربهم على
الاراضي التركيه او من الاردن السلفيين او
من من من الحدود اللبنانيه او حتى من
الحدود العراقيه يعني ماذا تريد الدوله ان
تعطيهم المفاتيح وتذهب على هذا حل لن
تعطيها المفاتيح هناك مؤسسه جيش هناك
مؤسسه امنيه ستتعامل وهذا مطلب شعبي في
البدايه غرر البعض وقالوا حريه ومظاهره
لكن العمليه عمليه تخريب وضرب البن هذا
موضوع اخر غير موضوع هذه الحلقه العميد
صفوت اذا كان ما ذكره وتفضل به ضيفنا من
لندن صحيح بانها عمليات جراحيه المقصود
بها ضرب مجموعات معينه من دون التورط في
دفع فاتوره بشريه من الجنود جنود النظام
السوري هل هذه الضربات الجويه بطائرات
الميك كفيله بان تغي على الارض وبالتالي
هي معطى عسكري تقني ولا يجب فهمه خارج هذا
الاطار على الاطلاق على الاطلاق نحن الان
في قتال مدن نحن في قتال شوارع نحن في
قتال لنمط من مما يسمى حرب الجيل الرابع
مجرد اننا ندير الان يعني ا برنامجا عن عن
دمشق هذا ما يطلبه الثوار او المتمردون دع
باي اسم لدينا الان جزء من الحرب هي الحرب
التي ربما لها البعد المعنوي الان في
العالم كله يتحدث العالم عن ان طائرات
ثابته الجناح مقاتله مخصصه لمهاجمه جيوش
وارتل وتشكيلات ونظم معركه متكامله تقصف
بعض الاحياء وتدمر بعض الح هذا هو ما
يطلبه الثوار هولا يطلبوه من ناحيه
التدمير ولكن هذه هي الانكشاف التي يرغبون
في ان يظهرونها كيف للنظام ان يتحاور معه
العالم وهو لا يؤمن عاصمته ولكن عفوا يا
حضره العميد لماذا يختلف الوضع عندما
نتكلم على انه طائرات النظام قصفت اكثر من
مكان وعندما نقول بان الوضع يختلف عندما
يتعلق الامر بالعاصمه دمشق وليس بريفها
حتى حي في داخل العاصمه دمشق انت دائما
تبحث عن ما نسميه الهجمات المشهديه انت
تبحث عن اكثر شيء يشد العالم اليك اذا
تحدثت عن معركه تتم على سب المثال في
الباره او اليادوده او مناطق اخرى نسمع
عنها او الميادين او مسكنه او ما نعيش فيه
على مدار الساعه وتتكلم اليوم عن جوبر
تتكلم عن دمشق تتكلم عن العاصمه التي بها
راس الدوله التي بها القياده السياسيه
والعسكريه العليا انت تتكلم عن حدث كبير
تتكلم على انك وصلت ال العمق حتى الان في
العمليات التقليديه بين الدول كنا في
الماضي نهتم بقتال الهوامش ولا تصل الى
الوسط الا متاخر اليوم حتى بالتقنيه
الجديده اصبحت اصبح القذف في قلب العاصمه
حتى في الشكل التقليدي فما بالك الان في
حرب التمرد هل يستطيع المتمردون الان او
الثوار الان ان يتحدثوا انهم يديرون معركه
من تل شهاب في الجنوب الى اعزاز في الشمال
يستطيعون هل يستطيعون انهم يقولوا انهم
يسيطروا على معابر في البوكمال ويتقدمون
الان الى اليعقوبيه وربما مناطق ممسه مع
تركيا يقولون هذه الجغرافيا الكامله ارهقت
النظام هم في معركه الان لارهاق لتفتيت
لتمزيق جهد النظام ويبدو حتى من حديث
الزميل من لندن هو يعترف الدمشق غير مسيطر
عليه كيف لنا ان نتحدث عن نظام كيف نتحدث
كيف نتحدث عن جيش لم يؤمن حتى عاصمته
السياسيه هذه المعضله الكبيره التي الان
تواجه النظام حتى اننا في حاله استغراب
شديد نحن الباحثين في المسار استراتيجيه
كنا دائما في اي صراعات سابقه نستمتع بان
كثير من المقالات والاراء تكتب عن
استراتيجيه الطرفين حتى الان انا اجد
غرابه شديده لا احد يتحدث عن النظام ما هي
استراتيجيته يبدو ان الامر تائه يعني مفر
فط لان الوقت ينا العميد صفوت اتوجه الى
ضيفي في لندن السيد في اسطنبول عفوا السيد
وليد البني عن ان كانت هناك رساله ايضا
يريد النظام ان يوصلها للعالم في ظل هذا
الصمت الدولي ساست كل ما لدي من اجل اجهاض
ما يجري على
الارض في الحقيقه ما يجري هو انه وجد ان
لا جواب على كل جرائمه استخدم الدبابه قصف
بواسطه الدبابات لم يكن هناك جواب لا من
المجتمع الدولي ومع كل اسف ولا من اصدقاء
سوريا ولا مع اشقائها خسرنا الى حد الان
اكثر من 50 ال شهيد دمر حوالي ث سوريا تم
تدميره لحد الان لم يج قريحه المجتمع
الدولي تفتات اخيرا عن هدنه لمده اربعه
ايام دون اي اسس لتطبيقها او مراقبه يعني
عمليا لا شيء هذا سيجر النظام بانه يستطيع
ان يدمر حتى دمشق دون ان يكون هناك رادعا
ولكن ما اريد ان اقوله الشعب السوري حسم
امره وهذا النظام سيرحل ما نطلبه نحن من
كل من لديه ضمير انساني ان يرحل هذا
النظام دون ان نقتل ملايين السوريين ودون
ان تصبح سوريا مدمره انا اعتقد ان عدم
وجود رد دولي رادع سيدفع هذا المجرم الذي
اعتقد انه فقد عقله لا يمكن كما قال الاخ
سباهي من لندن بانه يريد ان يوفر حياه
اربع جنود فيدمر مدينه عدد سكانها 100000
يعني هذا اغبى تحليل سمعته حقيقه لا فقط
فقط عذرا عذرا سيد وليد عذرا سيد وليد ع
سيد وليد فقط نحاول ان ننتقي مصطلحاتنا
ليس البرنامج التجريح ولكن للتحليل لا لا
انا لا اقول لا انا لا لا اهين السيد
سباهي بس اقول ان التحليل ليس ذكيا ما
هكذا تقدم التحاليل انه لا يريد ان ان ان
يضر باربع جنود هؤلاء الجنود يقصفون
اهاليهم فيدمر مدينه ويقتل 50 طفل في معره
النعمان او اكثر من 60 في المره الماضيه
في منطقه 500 في داريه وانتم قدمتم برنامج
عنرك
ا
من اسطنبول المعارض والناشط السياسي
السوري وليد البني كما اشكر ضيفي من لندن
هيثم سباهي عضو النادي الاجتماعي السوري
واشكر ضيفي هنا في الاستديو العميد صفوه
الزيات الخبير في الشؤون العسكريه
والاستراتيجيه بهذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر نلتقي باذن الله في
قراءه جديده فيما وراء خبر جديد الى
اللقاء باذن
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الله
[موسيقى]
di